[Music]
this is what it's all about celebrating
[Music]
how incredible is it that we have so
much
fun at et canada that we are out here
celebrating together e.t canada's got
pride chorus-wide oh my goodness the
first pride was 12 years ago i was
pregnant with my son and just feeling
the love it's just such a beautiful time
we have so many allies within the office
we have a lot of queer people within the
office and this is what it's all about
being out here showing our support it
was a celebration and a reunion with
friends of et canada popping up all over
the parade priyanka
you just posted are eating canada
celebration special you can't get rid of
me people i'm alright we're neighbors
now jazz we're neighbors gabers
neighbors you're gay
hello icon hi honey how are you i'm so
good i have interviewed you many times
but this is our very first time meeting
a person and what's a celebration
without some music anything missy elliot
or britney spears oh what britney spears
song
work
[Applause]
broken bones by loving old school baby
old school
today especially i was born this way
yeah out of an anthem i caught it
baby i was born